Hey guys! What we're going to see now is a
little bit of switching between me and Katie.
We share three languages, more than three languages
and we want to just show you how it is to switch
from one language to the other. It's just somethingfor the fun of it. We hope you're going to like it
Okay Katie so what we're going to do now like for
30 seconds one minute two minutes i don't know
we're just gonna have a conversation where wehave to switch and the only rule is that you have
to reply in a language that is different fromthe language I'm currently speaking in, right?
Katie (in Italian): I am scared!
Luca (in French): so, where are right now?
Katie: we are in Milan..
Luca (in Italian): I have never been to Milan, it is the first time
Katie (in French): oh! I myself live in Milan
Luca (in Italian): how long have you been living in Milan?
Katie (in French): 10 years, more or less
Luca: Wow, it's been a long time!
Why did you decid to go to Milan?
Katie (in Italian): Because I had a friend who used to live in Milan and...
Luca (in French): and that's it!
Katie (in Italian): yes, exactly!
Luca (in French): You just went for it! I'll go to Milan and stay there!
Luca (in Italian): do you like Milan?
Katie: yes
Luca (in Italian): we are getting confused!
Katie: Yes I like i like Milan, I didn't like it at first, in fact i was only supposed to come on holiday um
but then after a while i really like the lifestyle
because it feels quite small
even though it's a big city
Luca (in French): And where do you come from exactly, where were you born?
Katie (in Italian): I am English! I can't reply in French cause you just spoke French!
Luca (in Italian): you are right. Damn, I just spoke Italian! What a mess!
Luca (in English): so you were born in..where exactly?
Katie (in French): I was born in London but I grew up in Sheffield
Luca (in Italian): Ok, do you like Sheffield? Would go back and live there?
Katie: I like it but I wouldn't go back to livebecause I love languages and they don't speak so
it's it's harder to speak foreign
languages in Sheffield, not impossible but harder
Luca (in Italian): It is true! On the other hand is it possible to speak many languages in Milan?
Katie (in French): I can speak Italian for example, that's easy to do that
What about you? You live in Rome..do you speak a lot of languages every day?
Luca (in Italian): it is true, you are well informed,
I speak between 6 and 10 languages (every day), 10 languages
on a good day but it is rare but generally, I speak between 4 and 6 languages
at work and in my life in general. What about you? How many languages do you speak on a daily basis?
Katie: Probably just Italian on
a day-to-day basis. In fact,
my languages are a little bit rusty at the moment
Luca (in French): so you don't speak English, you don't speak it with your boyfriend, your friends in Milan..
Katie (in Italian): It is true! I speak English as well, you are right
Luca (in Italian): It is difficult not to speak English..
Katie (in French): Yes, it is true, it is quite difficult!
Luca: So this was a demonstration how to switch it, wasslightly challenging.. no? Katie: Yeah Luca: ..not to get confused
but you get the idea. This is no magic. it'sreally easy to change if.. it's a skill you develop
so it's something that you can easily develop. It's difficult to say something different
in a single conversation but I believe you can
manage if you have three different people and you
stick to one conversation at a time.. you know don't
constantly switch i think it's manageable right?
Katie: yeah yeah Luca: the last thing I wanted to
say is that everything is possible
you see? Everything is possible if you want it, you just have to put in some work. some discipline
and you can accomplish the impossible.Thank you very much and love from Milan